The answer is the first and the third.
The first is just
the Frobenius-Hall theorem, and
in fact this condition is equivalent
to there being a perfect matching.
A vertex cover of size L always exists,
just pick L.
Remember that the vertex cover
is just an upper bound, so
this does not imply that
there's a perfect matching.
Lastly, if there is a matching that
admits an alternating Hamiltonian cycle,
then there have to be half as many
matched edges as there are vertices,
which is the size of L.
Note that the implication
does not work the other way.
There are plenty of perfect matchings
that don't admit alternating
Hamiltonian cycles.